all that's left is the vote barring
something unforeseen the Senate is
expected to confirm Brett Kavanaugh as
an Associate Justice of the Supreme
Court later today
senators debated his confirmation all
night long and are still on the floor
this morning a vote is set for this
afternoon
Cavanaugh's nomination and Confirmation
set off a bitter partisan fight in the
Senate and it sparked a national
dialogue about sexual assault when
Christine Blasi Ford accused Kavanaugh
of attacking her 36 years ago when they
were teenagers on Friday four key
senators made their intentions known
following an FBI investigation into the
claims against Cavanaugh Arizona
Republican Jeff Flake said he would cast
his vote for Kavanagh Alaska's Lisa
Murkowski says she would not support
Kavanagh the sole Republican to break
from her party but Maine Susan Collins
announced she would vote YES
giving Republicans the 50 votes needed
for confirmation after Collins
announcement West Virginia's Joe Manchin
became the lone Democrat to say he would
also vote for Kavanagh Paula Reid will
have reaction from the White House but
we begin this morning on Capitol Hill
with Nancy Cordes good morning Nancy
good morning Michelle while Republicans
are relieved but no one is popping the
champagne corks just yet they will save
that until after the final vote later
today Democrats are still on the Senate
floor at this hour railing against the
nominee and against an FBI inquiry they
view as incomplete comes around
Democrats spent the night trying to get
their GOP colleagues to reconsider is
this someone who could sit on the
highest court on the land but Judge
Brett Kavanaugh as confirmation was
already all but assured after Republican
Susan Collins of Maine made this
announcement mr. president I will vote
to confirm judge Kavanagh her decision
came at the tail end of a brutal and
polarizing 88th day nomination process
that was rocked by a series of sexual
misconduct allegations against the
nominee late in the game protesters
tried to drown out Collins and West
Virginia's Joe Manchin on Friday became
the first and only Senate Democrat to
bat Cavanaugh I believe dr. Ford
something happened about before I don't
believe that the facts show that it was
Brett Kavanaugh Cavanaugh is a 53 year
old federal appeals court judge and
former White House lawyer for George W
Bush his confirmation today would give
conservatives a five-to-four majority on
the Supreme Court he fervently denies
pinning down Christine Blasi Ford and
groping her in 1982 I have never done
this to her or to anyone that's not who
I am it is not who I was
Ford made the allegation anonymously at
first before Kavanaugh was nominated I
was pushed onto the bed and Brett got on
top of me it was hard for me to breathe
and I thought that Brett was
accidentally going to kill me a limited
FBI background check last week did not
find solid proof for her claims the four
witnesses she named could not
corroborate any of the events of that
evening gathering where she says the
assault occurred but Senate Democrats
argued the FBI was prevented from
interviewing corroborating witnesses the
least this body could do was pause for a
moment and not to a sham FBI
investigation Ford's lawyers told CBS
News she is glad she came forward even
if Cavanaugh is confirmed she's given a
voice to hundreds of thousands of women
across the country across the world
who have been sexually assaulted so
those survivors have a voice and they
can look to dr. Ford as someone who had
the courage to stand up and those
lawyers put out an additional statement
late last night after it appeared that
Cavanaugh's confirmation was all but
assured they said quote we believe
Christine Blasi Ford and we fully
support her
senators claiming to want a dignified
debate should not repeat lies
constructed by the Judiciary Committee
that were cynically designed to win
support for Judge Cavanaugh
Anthony Nancy Cordes on Capitol Hill
where the debate is continuing before
the vote thank you Nancy